can we make climate action feel happy
instead of miserable the current
narrative on climate action is driveless
eat less Meat Shop less
less less so we came up with what we
call the happy climate approach its
actions in this sweet spot that not only
reduce emissions but also make you feel
happier at the same time instead of
shopping often
make shopping a treat Feng Shui your
fridge hatch things before they rot by
moving the perishables to the door and
the condiments into the drawers instead
of saying Drive less we should say drive
more
people because carpooling can turn those
Dreadful minutes behind the wheel into
joyful moments of socializing bundle
your trips cutting out unnecessary
flights can contribute to a sense of
time affluence the feeling that you have
enough time to do what you want to do
think about the actions you can take in
your own life